finishing things up now toca medera has
been a west hollywood hot spot since
2015 and now the high energy mexican
steakhouse has a las vegas location at
the shops at crystal and jc is live with
a preview hey jc
hey mercedes hey rocky this is so
exciting the restaurant opens up at four
o'clock uh grand opening today i'm here
with sasha uh with the restaurant
congratulations on the opening thank you
jason it's very exciting to finally be
able to introduce las vegas to something
we've been working so hard and i'm very
excited to have you and show you around
well there's such a vibe let's walk in
here how would you do come on in guys
how would you describe the vibe and the
feel of the restaurant well we describe
ourselves as a mexican inspired
steakhouse using a lot of bold flavors
in a very high energy and immersive
atmosphere and where you are right now
is our bar lounge area all these tables
you see offer a full dining menu as well
but this is part of the restaurant where
the lighting is a little bit more dimmer
and maybe the music is slightly louder
than it would be in the dining room so
you know we really want that energy to
exist here as soon as people walk in so
they really
respond to that before they begin their
experience you might walk in here or see
a celebrity or two sitting at a booth
having a cocktail i mean we'll see you
know they're either going to be here or
in one of the private rooms we have or
another room we have in the back that i
don't want to get too into the speaking
to the speakeasy
into that part sasha yeah cocktails
let's talk about the cocktails that you
have sorry i've just prepared three
uh of our favorites they're very
interactive and very delicious cocktails
curated by our beverage director
lorenzo very talented master mixologist
and i'm just going to get right into it
starting from the left essentially what
we have here is what we call our komola
floor all right watch this guys as i if
i may
oh
it's smoking smoking okay with the rose
petals to create that nice aroma i gotta
send it back here but you're known for
your fire and your drinks real quick
watch this guys this is a special
cocktail what's this cocktail called we
have our los muertos right here and our
nomamis
and then we just hit it with a little
bit of cinnamon oh it smells so good too
look at that
so what's in that what's in that drink
right there which one the one right here
yeah the one that's on fire so that one
is equal parts of mezcal and rum and
then we have a little bit of almond
syrup with red bell pepper juice with a
little bit of citrus so it's very
tropical and it's kind of our take of a
tikki cocktail and you guys know you
hear farm to table restaurants this is a
farm to cocktail absolutely our beverage
program is so dynamic and immersive and
using a lot of seasonal ingredients
it's truly something for everyone that's
gonna try here this is awesome we're so
excited the restaurant opens at four can
i try some of the food yes i actually
have chef waiting to talk to you in the
back right now okay come on come on
back to you guys in the studio hold on
we got to drink these i'll send it back
to you guys in the studio i'm going to
cry
okay those drinks look nice but let me
try some of the food please
the toco madeira is a vibe i've been to
the one in l.a so many times so i'm
excited for so glad it's here all right
jc we will check